this time on banded Patrol oh my
goodness there's a new cat in town we've
never rehabilitated a bobcat before but
the Allen family loves new challenges
and this Kitty's Got Claws
then I'm gonna help you a blind opossum
takes on the fight of her life I'm not
giving up Hope on her yet finally oh
gosh Kristen and Grant play a game of
wildlife Shoots and Ladders here we
think that we're gonna put this bird up
in the tree and then I'll pack bracelets
please be careful
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's the start of a new adventure for
wildlife rehabilitators Kristen Allen
and her son Grant today they are picking
up a baby bobcat which was found
orphaned by two other local rehabbers
hey guys how are you
so I get a call from another Wildlife
rehabilitator that says she has a bobcat
and they just don't have a facility for
it we've never rehabilitated a bobcat
before so we're super excited that we
get this challenge put upon us
heavy Bobcat how little is he
I would say about seven or eight weeks
about two pounds a little over two
pounds all right you want to see him
yeah I do
[Music]
put your double gloves on those are
Kevlar I hope those are good you'll need
them even though he's little I am
telling you from the beginning Bobcats
are vicious oh my goodness isn't he
beautiful that cute little face is just
like as my mom used to say cute don't
cut it because that personality is not
cute his instincts are there he knows
that he's a bobcat and he knows what
he's supposed to do so we need to make
sure that everyone stays safe including
the Bobcat does anybody know what
happened to the mom no it's pretty
obvious it had been without the mother
for a while he was pretty thin
dehydrated covered in ticks Mama's rough
tongue just wipes those ticks off when
they clean them so that's how you know
this Bobcat was totally emaciated
covered in ticks he definitely would
have died out in the wild these
rehabbers really saved his life
here we'll just kind of do a calm hand
over here he likes it when you cradle
his back he seems to be the calmest
look how big those pawls are the ticks
are still falling off of him from where
we put the spray but you can still see a
tick in between his toes yeah that's
dried up and dead
he had hundreds he looks really good
though
I promise you I will take good care of
this guy
Bobcats do not do not come into
Rehabilitation very often because
they're very elusive even out in the
wild people do not see them very often
and so rehabilitating a baby bobcat
makes me a little nervous but the Allen
family loves new challenges and we're up
to the challenge of getting this Bobcat
ready to go out in the wild
temperatures are soaring in Western
Kentucky okay we're here let's go get a
bat and Wildlife rehabber Nikki
Christian is at the local courthouse to
help a bat beat the Heat
hello
hey are you the lady with the bat I am
all right it's nice to meet you my
name's Nikki and Darlene where's the bed
at now he is all cozy in this little
crack oh my gosh he is
so was he just like crawling across the
road
my boss noticed something hobbling like
a big it looked like a big spider across
the street yeah and he come right on
across the street and got in that little
crack he's been there ever since could
you see him like actually moving all of
his little limbs he hobbled across the
street yeah but I don't think he can fly
okay well we'll try to get him out of
there
it's not good for a bat to be on the
ground like this especially with this
heat he could literally Cook Out Here
something's definitely wrong with him
I know you don't want to come out
I wouldn't want to come on either
nice and cool down there hi baby
oh okay I know I know I'm so sorry sweet
I love bats they're probably one of my
favorite things the mosquitoes they kill
alone oh my gosh
bats they get a bad rap it's a big
misconception that all bats have rabies
and that's just not true it's less than
one percent they're absolutely amazing
animals there's no reason to be afraid
of them he looks like he's moving
everything so nothing looks broken
all right well I'm gonna get him in here
and um and get him home and to see how
he does
I don't know exactly what's going on
with this bag I want to really examine
him well make sure he's not dehydrated
there's no broken bones no little tears
in his wings and kind of look him all
over a little bit closer all right thank
you again thank you
meanwhile back in Owensboro the Allen
family gets their first good look at the
baby bobcat they will raise over the
next several months they got the
majority of the chicks off of him he's
so small he's a lot smaller than I
thought he was going to be like he's
already getting the black tips on his
ears
I'm gonna guess what he is close to two
months at least
show that tick right there yeah
there's another one
she said that they got hundreds of the
ticks off
trying to see his teeth yeah
yeah his fight is already way stronger
than a normal house cat oh yeah
look at those big sharp teeth
when we deal with this Bobcat safety is
going to be a big issue for us he can
bite through welding gloves right now
and he is a month and a half two months
old maybe just imagine whenever he is
full grown he is going to have such a
strong bite force so we're gonna need to
be very careful with it careful is right
as an adult this Bobcat will be able to
take down prey up to nine times his own
body weight all right we have to name
him okay now
hour and a half
to
think
I know that you guys love it when I come
up with names no I do
you have some good names okay you ready
Bobcat Marley
okay yeah
[Music]
it's Connie I know it's good I like it
you're the only one that appreciates my
humor
he's not injured at all so we just need
to
do that first step work on what he
Adrian you want to bring that food and
water over here why don't you put it in
his cage before we put him in there
because he really does like taking a
swipe at things
you ready buddy
other rehabbers did a fabulous job of
stabilizing him now we need to put some
weight on this guy are you hungry buddy
we're gonna feed him raw meat with the
bone in it because that extra calcium is
exactly what this baby needs who knows
how long he's been without mom's milk
without Mom hunting for him so we want
to make sure that anything he's been
lacking we make up for now
[Music]
being a licensed Wildlife rehabilitator
is not for the faint of heart for
Bridgette Williams hurt animals are some
of her most challenging rescues but they
are also her most rewarding I'm on my
way to find an adult a possum that has
some pretty severe injuries the collar
has informed me that she thinks one of
the eyeballs had popped out of socket so
I'm sure this guy is going to be in
really really bad shape
[Music]
all right let's find this little awesome
are you waiting for me
listen oh you're very welcome membership
with Second Chances Wildlife Center so
what happened you've been here I went to
work and when I got back around eight he
was laying there oh I see him oh my
goodness
when I first glanced at this opossum my
heart just dropped
when I see any animal suffering I suffer
a little bit inside as well I hate to
see any animal in pain and I just want
to help them it's okay it's okay
poor thing
this opossum has a fractured eye she has
one eyeball literally hanging out of her
socket
seeing the severity of her eye damage
I'm sure there could be internal issues
[Music]
you could tell that he is having trouble
breathing
little snores
it's okay baby it's okay
the tongue is very swollen and bloody
too
it's okay baby it's okay
I'm gonna help you I'm gonna help you
I appreciate you calling
I mean he's just sitting there
yes exactly if it weren't for Katie the
lady that found the opossum and called
me this opossum would have just been
left in this parking lot to slowly die
Katie said she felt an automatic
connection to this opossum because her
mother used to be a wildlife
rehabilitator and unfortunately passed
away five years to this day so she felt
like her mother had somehow brought her
to this opossum
time is very critical right now this
opossum's injuries look so severe
I can't waste two hours going to the
center and then take her to that she
needs to go ASAP
[Music]
not wanting her injured opossum to
suffer more than it has to Bridgette
Williams beelines for the vet's office
thanks for seeing her so quickly
no flies are damaged oh yeah
it was a no-brainer that when I first
looked at this opossum I knew she would
never regain her sight
I can work with the fact that she'll
being blind my biggest concern at this
point is just to see how severe her
internal injuries may or may not be and
if they're so bad the only option
unfortunately is just to help put her
out of her suffering she seems to have a
good grip with all four feet her Tail's
good I can feel a soft spot but
she seems to be alert and aware and
moving we want to get x-rays the damage
everywhere and we didn't see anything
that really indicated that she needed to
be euthanized immediately but one of her
eyeballs was basically hanging out of
its socket the other one had been
completely destroyed so we'll need to
kind of assess the severity of the
fractures to her skull and potentially
brain injury
we've got fractures front front
discipline right here should be
continuous with this okay just like this
one is she probably got run over right
across the top of her nose getting hit
by a car like this opossum did is really
awful most the time it's by accident
when humans hit animals but she's barely
hanging on to life and that makes me
very sad
what we don't know is how much the
cranium moved and that it really is what
determines the damage to the brain the
compression fractures to her skull could
have caused really severe injury to
certain parts of her brain that injury
can continue to get worse so even though
she came in
functional and able to walk and grasp
those injuries May progress to a point
where she becomes unconscious or
comatose what she's going to be capable
of recovering from is going to be a
matter of time if she can survive you
can give her a chance if you want
yeah let's give her a little bit of time
let her tell us which way she wants to
choose
yeah I mean she's going to declare
with the years of experience I have had
with Wildlife I know that they will let
me know if they're willing to put up the
fight for the Long Haul Dr Jewell is
going to treat her eyes today I'm going
to take her back to the center and
really pay attention to what she is
telling me but I'm not ready to give up
hope yet
good
four weeks older in double his original
weight Bobcat Marley Is Now healthy
enough for a quick but important step in
his Rehabilitation hey Grant you want to
come help me for a minute yeah
I'm gonna give him his feline December
vaccine okay you draw it up before we
get to him with any animal you're always
concerned about imprinting and with a
bobcat we definitely don't want him to
approach anyone in the wild so we're
going to be as hands off as we can
possibly be but we have to vaccinate him
so the goal when we vaccinate Bobcat
Marley is to do this quickly and
painlessly as possible let's just get
him out and get him a shot
going back in you ready I'm ready hey
there buddy
that's a good one I know did you have
two gloves on right
[Music]
here
okay let me get in position better
foreign
go for it
there you go
if he needs something that we have to
touch him then we will touch him but
basically this is a hands-off raising of
this animal if we do our job correctly
as rehabbers this Bobcat is not going to
want anything to do with us and that's
exactly what we want
I'm sorry buddy I don't like you I know
and it's just as it should be now Bobcat
Marley just needs to grow a little bit
more and then he gets to go to his big
outdoor enclosure that big outdoor
enclosure is going to make him bigger
stronger and Wilder
towns away from Kristen
what's going on with this little guy
Nikki tries to figure out why her newly
rescued bat was in that crack by the
courthouse in the first place a
courthouse bat we'll call him Bayless
they left the bat
considering how hot it has been
I figured that he was dehydrated but he
doesn't look bad at all his eyes are not
sunken in at all and actually the inside
of his mouth looked good and pink you
know looking at this bat now I'm kind of
thinking that I might have had this all
wrong maybe something happened to the
mom maybe he just got orphaned just got
lost
I think bailiff is just a young bat and
just is not ready to fly it he was stuck
out in the Heats and he was trying to
find any place cool and that crack was
the first place that he found you're
going to eat a little bit
the fact that he might be orphaned you
know for a few days then he's probably
hungry
[Music]
I squish that that's out maybe he'll
like that
This Bat is not interested in this
mealworm so I'm going to tear it in half
and kind of get those juices flowing and
see if it'll kind of kick in that
instinct
[Music]
know it
there good job
yummy yummy
oh my goodness so yeah now you know what
I've got holy moly
it's chilling down he's liking this
you see Bayless right now taking these
mealworms it's a good thing that he is
not out of the woods because they can
look fine one minute and not be okay the
next I'm Gonna Keep a close eye on him
to make sure he's eating good make sure
that everything's working the way it's
supposed to be working and then the next
step is just getting ready to fly you
are so cute
[Music]
Bobcat Marley is tucked away at the
Allen house so Kristen and Grant take a
two-hour Trek to answer a raptor
emergency call
hey there how are you good how about you
I'm Kristen Sharina Grant nice to meet
you guys so you have a baby I do I do uh
yesterday on the way home from school we
drove in and found this little guy on
the ground next to the tree how long has
he been out of the nest yesterday we
came home at 3 15. so I'm not sure you
know before that how long he's been out
let me pick him up and we'll check him
out just make sure you want to get hurt
falling out of the nest
oh you're adorable
he looks good he doesn't look like he
has any head trauma good his legs feel
good Everything feels normal to me he's
like I'm just still a baby
thankfully he does have some of his
primary feathers so he didn't just like
plummet to the ground and go plop he
actually kind of fell with style
he's not injured so all we have to do is
get him back in the nest do you think
there's any more in the neck we noticed
mom she was up feeding okay okay we
could see one more little one up there
okay so you're gonna show me where the
nest is
so it's this tree here and if you look
at holy guacamole you'll see the the
nest
[Music]
okay
see right there
and so it is a good way
as I look up into the tree and it's 40
feet up this Nest is
I'm thinking to myself unless my son
Grant can learn how to fly there's no
way he's getting this bird back up in
that tree
um
[Music]
about 40 feet stand between this baby
red-tailed hawk in his nest
Kristen and Grant face a real head
scratcher okay
well
what are you thinking I'm looking to see
if there are any branches that I could
climb up on
oh my goodness
yeah there's no way I can climb up yeah
okay let's
do you have a local fire department we
do that's what we're gonna have to do if
we want to get him back in the nest I
think the only chance is us getting the
fire department to get involved I know
in every other rehabber knows that the
best place for these animals to be are
with their parents and this mom's still
around if I have to call the fire
department to get this bird back up in
the nest that's what I'm gonna do I'll
call the fire department
[Music]
hey there my name is Kristen Allen and
this is probably the craziest call that
you're going to get like today or this
month but um I'm a wildlife
rehabilitator and I actually came from
Owensboro because a baby hawk fell out
of a nest and it's probably 40 feet up
the nest is so desperately I'm calling
you to see if there's any way the
volunteer fire department would bring a
truck out here and help us get this baby
back up in the nest
all right thank you so much all right
bye-bye
he's gonna do it
so as soon as he gets off work he's
going to be here I will send you a text
that'd be great and let you know when
he's back in the next Perfect all right
thank you thank you so much I appreciate
it this is our last resort
the fire department going to be able to
help us do it that's the question
almost two days after being hit by a car
brigette's blind opossum is still in
critical condition I'm just watching her
breathe a little bit it's always good to
take time just to observe the animals
because you can learn a whole lot just
by a simple observation
there's several things that I'm looking
for with this opossum is she moving
around a little bit is she able to eat
some soft foods it's going to let me
know if I'm able to continue down the
road of her recovery or if it ends here
and we will just have to peacefully let
her go on her own
first I'm going to give her some pain
meds
she cannot be very comfortable at the
moment
sure this will make her feel a lot
better right there's pain medicine now
for the antibiotics which have to be
given to her very slowly
she's a very patient patient for sure
right now I don't see any signs of brain
damage however it would make me feel
more confident in her recover if she
would show me a few more signs that
she's improving
I'm gonna get her just a little bit of
water there baby
since she's primarily breathing through
her mouth it gets really dry it's just
like if you and I have a cold and we're
breathing through our mouth we're
probably going to get a dry mouth as
well
she's trying to drink it that's a good
sign
she might actually be swallowing it
which would Thrill Me
I think she didn't just follow that yay
yesterday when I was putting a little
bit of liquid in her mouth she would
just shake it out I think her throat was
still too swollen to swallow anything
and now it looks like she's swallowing
it so
this is very exciting
I always have a tendency to root for the
underdog this opossum definitely is an
underdog but Katie and her mother's
story was very special and I really just
want this opossum to survive all right
little one that's it for today
re-nesting a red-tailed hawk is not
usually part of a fireman's job
description
but today the Grand Lakes fire
department will try to use their skills
to help Kristen and Grant do just that
all right you guys ready
I'm Kristen Christopher Ross Charles one
it's nice to meet you this is my son
Grant
all right so this is the baby that came
out of the nest let me show you where it
is I'm like it's
way up there see right that second thick
branch there yeah
how tall is your ladder
it's 35 foot how tall do you think that
is
it's going to be close are you going to
take the bird up I yeah if that works
for you yeah we can give it a shot and
see okay
This Is The Moment of Truth is the fire
department going to be able to get Grant
up there to get this hawk in the nest
okay
as far as he gonna go
we haven't seen the mother Hawk and we
really don't want to tangle with a mom I
know how like I am with my children
nobody better mess with them and I
certainly don't want Grant have to mess
with his mama Hawk
all right here you go Bud you're going
in
next place is the nest
before you climb on a branch make sure
the branch is secure okay
don't fall okay I won't
seriously Grant be careful
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
hey are there any other babies up there
yeah there's two more in the nest okay
whoop that's a fledgling
oh gosh dagnabbit there goes but another
fledgling
so as Grant is putting the baby hawk up
in the nest all of a sudden these two
other Hawks start jumping out of the
nest and I'm thinking oh my gosh can
this get any worse
[Music]
red-tailed Hawks are literally falling
out of the sky in Grand Rivers Kentucky
here we think that we're going to put
this bird up in the tree everything's
gonna be wonderful and then all heck
Breaks Loose one jumps out and it's in
the next train then the other one Glides
down he gets in the lake and I'm like oh
my gosh what is going on here this was
supposed to be simple once the ladder
got here
we really need to grab that other one
yeah so I'm gonna have to climb that
tree to grab that one
okay
you know the bottom line is that the
nest is best for these birds that's
where they need to be worst case
scenario if I have to take them home
because they keep jumping out of the
nest I will but that's gonna be my last
option
please be careful
you're okay buddy
watch their branches and break
as Grant is up in the tree I can imagine
how that mother Hawk feels because those
baby hawks are branching out on those
branches and my son is up on one of
those branches right now let me come up
and grab him just just so you don't here
uh here you go there's a bird in there
not quite ready yet give me one second
here oh my goodness
um uh don't fall Mom sorry Mom I love
you just stand there
[Music]
you're okay buddy
watch out let me grab you that's all
right
got him
Great's an adult but worry about your
children you know like the mother Hawk
wants to take care of her baby hawks I'm
gonna take care of my son too will you
guys hold one more time for us
okay
[Music]
so we came down here to re-nest one bird
and actually we're gonna end up
re-nesting three but if they keep
jumping out of the nest I'm gonna have
no choice but to take them with me
don't jump it's okay I'm putting your
brothers back up here okay
don't do it
if he's on a close Branch just leave him
no he's still on it we're good okay
here you go no no no no stop
there you go
don't push your brother off
it's okay
[Music]
you know it was a little chaotic Birds
jumping out of the nest having to call
the fire department but all in all it
worked out perfectly because these
babies are back safe where they need to
be with their mama
after three weeks under Nikki's watchful
eye bailiff the bat should be able to
start flying the Asian big day with
animals in general there's a lot of
things I could teach them flying is not
one of them bailiff is an orphan so he's
going to have to learn to fall on his
own
come on out there and no I'm taking a
nap but it's time to wake up he has got
to fly to survive so I've got to make
sure that he knows how to fly before I
can release him
you're okay
foreign
[Laughter]
he took off within just a few seconds of
me opening my hand but he turned around
and went right back into his enclosure
he did
I know it's a big scary world but you
gotta come on out come on let's hurt
again even though he feels safe in there
he's got to come back out we've got to
do this again I need to see more flight
out of him
come on
spread them Wings baby doll
there you go
it was a short flight but you flew oh no
love you can't get up there
he can fly this is a good sign but you
know what I want to see how long he can
stay in flight
and right now he's just wanting to climb
nope not really call me her I want you
to fly and then I can release you
what
[Music]
I'm so proud of you
when bailiff took offline it was one of
the prettiest things I have ever seen in
my entire life yes a bat is pretty you
were doing so good bailiff I'm super
excited
I have seen bailiff eating and now I've
seen him for one all his muscles are
good and strong there is nothing
stopping me from releasing him back into
the wild who is the biggest baddest of
bat around save data
now weighing in at over 10 pounds Bobcat
Marley has outgrown his indoor cage and
is ready to start using his claws you
ready to go with the outdoor enclosure
Marley
you just wait do you see how big it is
outside it's going to be much bigger and
nicer for you out there
this one's double gloved so hopefully he
doesn't go through it but I'm guessing
he very well still could
I need to move very slowly to grab
Bobcat Marley because he is very
defensive and very aggressive so I need
to do this very carefully without
injuring myself or injuring the bobcat
ready Marley
yeah I think that's it now
you're okay
Heather
foreign
[Music]
hey calm down calm down it's okay
[Music]
it's okay
you're okay
it's okay you're doing good Grant
no no
no
no
it's okay it's okay
oh my God
okay Marley it's okay Marley was a real
little Dickens he put up quite a fight
and I was just so happy when Grant
finally got him in that little transport
cage okay
all right he's coming out here the last
time you have to get him out of there I
know positive thing that should be the
last time that we made contact with him
yeah all right ready yeah
Marley's at the age now that he would
start going with his mother and hunting
outside the dam so with Marley being in
this huge outdoor enclosure he's going
to be able to hunt and practice all
those Natural Instincts that he was born
with
[Music]
Bobcat Marley's new outdoor home has
everything a growing Bobcat needs to
hone his survival skills
you ready buddy
hiss means yes is that what that means
Bobcat Marley's enclosure is incredible
because we've never rehabilitated a
bobcat before we did a lot of research
there are rocks to climb on there's a
den to sleep in there's a pond and much
like a zoo we've installed a little
Guillotine door so that we could be on
one side we can clean the other side and
put him we only go in this side getting
Marley into the big cage we had to think
about this so what we're gonna do is put
that transport cage up to the guillotine
door he's going to climb into one side
so we'll be safe on one side he'll be
safe on the other
he's already gone
he's smelling he's like this is all new
stuff and I'm excited
are you ready buddy
[Music]
all right
come on you can do it
[Music]
come on Marley
ah there he goes
oh
so he went straight into the green
reader yeah Bobcat Marley being
comfortable in this enclosure is really
important
let's go while he's up in that corner
yeah Bobcats have a tendency to hide but
Marley didn't hide for long and I'll
take that as a compliment for our
handiwork I really thought he would run
and hide first thing I did too he's
really happy to be out in the bigger
space exactly
just think he's going to get at least
twice the size that he actually is now
Bobcat Marley could grow to be upwards
of 30 pounds and strong enough to jump
as high as 12 feet in the air
now the Bobcat Marley is in the outdoor
enclosure there will only be live prey
given to him he's gonna have to hunt for
his food I'm going to start him out on
small mice and then we're going to get
bigger from there
let's see what he does
oh he says that didn't take me long did
it is he eating you I can tell by the
way Bobcat Marley is hunting but he's
going to be able to do great out in the
wild but he's got to grow a lot bigger
so that he can defend himself against
other wild animals
as Bobcat Marley grows we're going to
have to start thinking about how we're
going to release this boy because we're
going to have to transport him safely so
that we don't get hurt and he doesn't
get hurt
[Music]
in Louisville Kentucky brigette's blind
opossum shows small signs of improvement
hi baby
but there's still one major hurdle
I can care for any blind animal what I
need her to do on her own is eat
I brought you some good stuff I'm hoping
this yummy flavor yogurt will entice her
to eat on her own
it
there you go
yeah that's the good stuff
this is the first time she's just eaten
anything
he's hungry
yay
she's able to sit up I'm excited to see
that
not only is she eating but she's able to
move her jaw this is something I wasn't
sure she was going to be able to do
I think you've licked it clean though
one more drop she said I am so excited
the progress that this opossum is making
I had a lot of doubts but she showed me
that she was a fighter and she showed me
that I should fight along with her
it's amazing recovery just amazing
[Music]
court is finally in session for bailiff
the bat and this bailiff is ready to be
set free this is where foreign
yeah
close so he'll still know the area but
in what we're right here where all this
just it's just nothing to concrete let's
do it near the trees
it's important for me to release bailiff
back where he came from because bats
live in colonies and this is where his
colony is and he needs to be with his
family
all right baby doll
come on
you ready
it's your time to fly
you can do it
[Music]
did he go he blew that way and I slammed
back around this place
right there there he goes
towards the trees did he yeah you've got
better eyes than I do it's so cool
I cannot believe I missed him flying off
it was kind of like he was in my hand
one second and then he was gone but you
know what he disappeared into the night
just like he should good job
bye bayliff Wherever You Are
now six months old Bobcat Marley is
ready to fully Embrace his wild nature
you ready Marley I brought dinner
but before Kristen and Grant can release
him they have to catch him good let me
get out of here first
this is going to be tricky Bobcats are
nocturnal so Marley's curled up in his
little Den fast asleep but we need to
get him into this transport cage without
putting our hands on it I put some mice
into the transport cage to try and lure
him out of that Den but if that doesn't
work we're gonna have to try and figure
out some other way to get him in there
oh yeah do the happy dance oh yeah
okay Marley
sorry Marley we are taking you to the
most awesome place though
I know I know I'm sorry thank goodness
we got him in there
and nobody touched him and nobody got
hurt
watch your hand mom
it's pretty stressed out since we had a
traffic to get him to his release
location Marley is by far this most
aggressive animal I've dealt with and to
get such a top predator out in the wild
it's absolutely amazing
Kentucky may be known for their Wildcats
but Bobcats are hunted here so Kristen
finds the ideal place to release Marley
hey Marley that's a long ride wasn't it
this place that we picked for Marley
could not be more perfect there's tons
of acreage it's private land and best of
all no hunting
you ready Marley there's lots of rabbits
out here and quail you know it okay on
three one
two
[Music]
it's a big world out there and it's all
yours
oh there he goes
[Music]
don't go in there
like it's a cave
wouldn't you know it out of all the open
land here Marley goes straight for the
abandoned shed well if that's where he
wants to make his home tonight then
that's where he wants to make it home in
there in here and you know what I bet
they're a mice in there
I just wanted shelter for the night
exactly all right let's go
it's not the dream release that I
imagine but I'm not worried because he's
got a lifetime to explore these Woods I
was really hoping he'd show us how fast
he could run yeah well
we'll have to wait for the next one next
one that's right
Marley is going to thrive out here he's
not going to approach humans look what
he did the first thing he did was find
the safest place to get away from the
Allen Family
Marley Marley Marley
[Music]
it's been three months since the blind
opossum first came into brigette's care
and her recovery has been nothing short
of miraculous today The opossum's
Rescuer Katie is here to see her for
herself
hey Katie hey how's it going good how
are you doing
I can't wait to eat her so excited
oh my God can you believe she looks so
great she does
hi baby girl
look I had some treats for you
she recognizes my voice
so alert she's for having us
I think these are good treats
we were worried that her jaw is slightly
out of line but I think that has worked
its way out to where she can eat pretty
well
she is brilliant I absolutely love her
[Music]
she looks so happy because of your call
if you didn't call she wouldn't be here
my mom always taught me just to help
anything that you can help you know
Katie and her mother's story was very
special to me and my team so I feel that
an appropriate name for this Apostle is
a wonderful way to pay tribute to Katie
and her mother
she has the name
and I think you will appreciate this
name we name her angel and that was
partially because of your mom that used
to rehab and the whole story of how you
thought that she brought you to this
opossum and in her memory of the day of
her fasting so her name is Angel thank
you yes you are very welcome you're very
welcome
[Music]
I think the Angels story will definitely
end fire people she came in in such
severe condition that euthanizing her
was definitely an option but Angel did
not give up and I did not give up on
Angel she's going to have a great life
here at Second Chances she's my little
miracle
[Music]
thank you
[Music]